you'll see I did not initiate the
physical confrontation but you did
finish it though oh check
hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
my buddy Patrick Bet David is making
sense as he usually does thank you for
handling a little of the nonsense pbd
while I am God what was the fight all
about I thought I'm like what are they
fighting because obviously you guys are
not you're speaking in uh
what had happened it was right at the
height of this reporting I was doing in
Brazil that was extremely tumultuous it
was really kind of shaking the country
to its its foundations so it was very
polarizing and the person with whom I
had had this fight had gone on his own
show I think maybe
like six weeks earlier and it said
something like you know my husband
um who recently passed away but at the
time he was a member of Congress and I
was in the middle of this uh this the
doing this journalism and he said
something like what I want to know is
they have they adopted two kids they're
raising two kids who's taking care of
these kids he's a congressman he's doing
all this in Brasilia the other
ones dealing with stolen documents who's
raising the kids as though it's uncommon
these days for kids to have two parents
who are working I think we need to judge
a minor judge to go and investigate
whether these kids should be taken out
of the home so if there's anything that
you know as a father someone can say
that is going to make you kind of angry
it's maybe you should have your kids
taken away from you and then when I got
to this interview he wasn't supposed to
be there they told me at the last minute
he would be
I said fine I'm happy to talk to anybody
they sat him down I don't know if you
saw the video go to 417. trust me I saw
it inches look at how close we were oh
my God like sitting on top of each other
Glenn you're ready to throw down at this
point yeah
you know you're sizing up his Jaws I
mean I was you know they wanted they
they started off by like hey let's talk
about the news and I said yeah before we
do that I'm gonna need an apology there
we go Glenn Greenwald getting it in
right there you'll see I did not
initiate the physical confrontation but
you did finish it though oh glad
glad oh Glenn oh Glenn you gotta block
your face about to come wait wait for it
five seconds hold on five seconds
[Music]
did you slap him yeah I mean it
was hard you see this gigantic guy that
was like the Jerry Springer security
team hit me back so there was only so
much I could do I had never been in a
physical conversation on a news program
before it's not like I go around
engaging in fistically is this a Big
Show no yeah it's a gigantic it's like
one of the biggest shows in Brazil